our next speaker got into the craze and
still every day plays
Wordle please welcome
Irina okay so uh my name is enina I'm a
senior scientist who has wandered her
way down from uh Chile Canada to talk to
you guys today about targets
now when I say pipelining some people
may think this kind of pipelining but
actually the kind of pipelining that I
want to talk about today looks more like
this so um we have sort of some objects
in those round um represented by those
circles and then we have some methods or
functions represented by triangles and
there are sort of arrows indicating how
things are related now there are many
ways to Define pipelining I'm leaving a
lot out here but the way I want to think
about it for the purpose of this talk is
that pipelining is the process of
writing down a recipe for outputs where
all your dependencies are stated
explicitly
so we we'll get into more what that
means in a bit and you might ask
yourself isn't that just a script um and
you know in some sense yes scripts can
be thought of as pipelines but for me
pipelining is so much more than just a
script so in my work I often get
requests like this because as a
scientist most of the work I do is in
modeling infectious diseases I've had a
busy few years unfortunately um but
things are better now thankfully and
sometimes my boss will come up to me and
say Hey you know there's this disease
it's picking up can you forecast it for
us for the next couple weeks or can you
set up a
model and and this is definitely the
kind of request that I might tackle with
a pipeline but there are other ones oh
sorry that um you might be more maybe
you may relate to more which is can you
clean this data set for the team or can
you make some plots for a presentation
next week or can you make figures and
tables for a paper if you're more on the
academic side those are all actually
examples of tasks that I've written
pipelines for as
well so as a concrete example let's
start with a very simple script that
might tackle that disease request so uh
we start with you know loading our
libraries we might read and clean the
data I'm doing a tremendous amount of
data cleaning as you can see um and then
I'm going to simulate um I have some
method that makes a forecast from the
data very mysterious I get out a
simulation and then I plot that
forecast and honestly this might be just
fine for what you need to do um and the
point of the talk is not to convince you
to always use a pipeline because that
would be silly the point is that I want
to motivate you to maybe look at adding
pipelines to your toolkit so that you
can be more efficient in your work
sometimes so this is fine sometimes but
then maybe my boss will come back to me
and say awesome can you add multiple
forcast scenarios and I'll be like okay
so now I'm revisiting my very simple
script and I have to make it more
complicated so an obvious way I know
this might turn some people off because
for Loops are a little taboo in the our
community I might have used L apply fine
but just suspend your sort of disbelief
that I'm doing this um I might just you
know set up a list of scenarios that are
labeled and there's something under the
hood there that makes this help me make
a forecast um and I'll Loop over those
scenario labels and pass that into my
make forecast function but this might be
a little slow if especially if those
simulations take a long time you know
there could be a bottleneck at from
lines 11 to
14 so I'm going to be really smart and
I'm going to have parallelization rescue
me right I could just you know a really
simple way is to call the do parallel
package set up a parallel parallel
processes and then uh for some reason
I'm I'm using four workers even though I
only have three tasks a little silly but
anyway um and I'm just going to kind of
loop over those scenarios in parallel
sure all of this works right there are
always going to be workarounds or other
ways of tackling this problem but what
if I only want to run certain scenarios
maybe for some reason I'm tweaking
scenario C because I'm not really happy
with how the outputs are looking if I'm
just running my script from top to
bottom all the time I'm being very
inefficient I'm rerunning scenarios A
and B which haven't changed right so
from a computer standpoint and from a my
time standpoint that's not really a good
use of
it uh what if I'm running into errors
for one scenario maybe it's not that I'm
trying to improve upon the results for
scenario C but I'm literally running
into bugs um I'm not going to want to
again run from top to
bottom or I step away from a meeting and
I have a notoriously poor memory um
that's what my friends say but uh I like
to say that I don't want to remember
things I don't have to remember or I can
write down um maybe I step away from a
meeting for a meeting and I come back to
my computer and I think uh wait which
one was I working on which results are
up to date what's going on here of
course you know for point one I could
edit the script and isolate the scenario
that is giving me trouble or I want to
improve upon for point to as well or
maybe I can go into my little finder or
Windows Explorer and look at when the
date modified was on some output objects
to figure out you know what's up to date
but the point is that's a lot to manage
I don't want to be sitting there
juggling things that I don't have to
juggle that someone who is way smarter
than me has written a package for um and
also I will mention targets which I'll
get to is not the only pipelining tool
this is a very common Concept in data
science there's so many tools out there
um but you know a lot of smart people
have put work into this so I don't have
to be sitting there finagling with my
script so that's where targets comes in
so this is ripped straight from the user
manual which was my top read of 2022 I
love that book um the targets package is
a make like pipeline tool for statistics
and data science and art I actually work
with dynamical systems models a lot I
mean not just I do some stats stuff as
well in data science sence so I would
argue it's really a great make it's
really sorry a great pipeline tool for
any tasks that you can do in r that Mak
sense to do an R um
so you for people who know what make is
you may have been sitting there on a
loop in your head like just use make
just use make what are you doing right
with your script um and my answer to
that is I don't want to um I've used
make before I actually really like make
but I used it more in my past life as an
academic as opposed to now as a
government uh scientist because in
government and sometimes in other
corporate settings lockdown settings it
an our package can actually be a lot
easier to
install and also to share with your
colleagues thanks to things like RN so
sometimes an our package staying within
the r ecosystem is really the way to go
there are workarounds for this you could
set up a Docker image you know and and
get your colleagues on board with like
command line tools and other things
Beyond R but you don't always have to
bring a gun to an KNE fight if you don't
have to so let's go into back into our
little script um that we had before that
was just fine and let's just look at
this um line here I'm going to translate
that to a Target in my pipeline so a
Target is something that the pipeline
makes now I'm going to use uh the
targets syntax it's quite simple
actually so we have to specify the name
of the target which corresponds to the
left hand side from our script in that
um assignment use an equals I know it
throws some people off but it it's the
same as the arrow assignment right um
and then we have the recipe for the
Target which is the right hand side of
the equal sign and it's just wrapped in
this tar Target statement that's all
it's a really very similar to writing up
a script uh or rather an element of a
script um but you can't Define targets
everywhere you can't just put them
anywhere they have to be uh in a
underscore targets file which is a
special file that defines your pipeline
thankfully it's really easy easy to set
this up there are some necessary
elements so the developer of targets has
given us a nice little utility you call
the library and then you call use
targets and it makes that file in the
main directory of your project so you
can just go in there it's got a bunch of
boilerplate you can tweak it as you need
um and go on so from that I can make
this pipeline so this is now aor
targets. R file that defines my Pipeline
and there's two main elements the first
one is the setup so there's uh we call
the libr Target so everything else under
will work and then we Source any uh f um
files that Define our functions because
targets is very function oriented so
generally the best practice is to write
a function to do the thing that makes
your target but you can of course as you
see later on just have naked sort of
code in there as
well and then we have to tell it what
packages it we need and this is
different from normally at the top of a
script we write Library package but
what's happening with Target is it's
actually calling a r subprocess in your
session to run your pipeline away from
your locally defined variables so that
you don't accidentally have it so that
your pipeline only runs when you have
certain things in your local environment
right it's kind of like putting things
in a sanitary box before it runs um and
it uses caller for that if you're
familiar with that package so we have to
pass sort of those arguments of like hey
remember to call these um packages
before you run the
pipeline and then the pipeline which I
know I've made sound really really like
big and cool what it's literally just a
list it's a list of targets great simple
and you can see I've included the three
elements of our original script I have
reading and cleaning data I have a
target for the simulation and I have a
target for the plot and so why have I
bothered to do this it looks just like a
script almost with a little bit of weird
syntax well there's a bit of a free
lunch now that you're using this package
you've sunk time into it not f F free
but there's there's some sort of free
things you get out of it it's really
easy to make stuff so once I have my
target names I can call tarake on a
Target name and I will get this in the
console it'll tell me I'm starting the
target data I've built it this is how
long it took it and so on and then at
the end what how long did my pipeline
take so you actually have some built-in
profiling if you're getting bottlenecks
in your code you can immediately see
which targets are taking longer than
others it's also easy to pull stuff out
once those targets have been made you
can read them in your interactive
session or into a quto dock or our
markdown or whatever and just pull them
up and you're getting the object back so
if this is a GG plot you can then add to
it you can add theming you can add
elements you can do other things so
that's really nice because it doesn't
require you to go back into your script
and find oh okay I have to run this
thing to get this into my local
environment it's all taken care of for
you so you don't have to do that
finagling or you can use charar load
which will literally load Lo the target
into your local environment under the
same name as the target so this pulling
this command will load an object called
plot with my plot into my local
environment it's really easy to
visualize the pipeline I love this
because with a script you have to kind
of read it and sketch it out yourself if
you're not sure how things interact
which if you're working with others and
they've Maybe started a process they've
you know started some analysis they
might have to sit down and explain to
you how the pieces interact with with
this command tarvis Network it basically
just lays it all out for you so we have
our three objects data Sim and plot and
then we have our two methods and while I
don't think I don't know that this will
work this is actually interactive so I
don't know why in these slides it's not
good but in the r Studio viewer or other
options you can actually drag these
targets around and the arrows move so
you can kind of see um right now it's
hard to see but plot forecast the arrow
for it actually goes through here to
plot so it's kind of overlaid it doesn't
actually Sim doesn't depend on it
there's no Arrow here but um anyway you
can kind of play around with it and I'll
point out this Legend here which is that
this dark force screen means that the
targets are up to date so I actually
wrote a pipeline in the background in
these slides and I ran it and it
actually made all of those targets so
now it's telling me everything's up to
date so nothing's changed um and what I
can do is I could maybe modify a
function so it's not just watching the
object it's watching all the
dependencies including your userdefined
functions so if I change how I'm
plotting maybe I change a point color or
something and then I run bz Network
targets will detect that change and it
will tell me hey you updated your plot
method so actually the dependent or the
downstream Target plot is now out to out
of date so if I were to run tarake again
it's not going to make data it's not
going to make Sim because those are up
to dat but it will rebuild plot so it's
skipping the stuff that it already has
made and is up to date which can save a
lot of
time basically it's only making what we
need and there's much much more which
I'll have to glaze over here because we
don't have time to get into it but
branching is really easy so if I have
sections of my pipeline like my forecast
simulation that I want to repeat for
different scenarios it's really it's
like a couple extra lines in your
pipeline to set up and then you're good
to go and with that going hand inand is
distributed computing there's really
nice new package uh called crew written
by the same developer that it used to be
with uh parallelization used to be done
with other packages but there's now a
sort of targets almost optimized a
parallelization uh package which is
really really nice and it literally you
can parallelize your pipeline with one
line of code
now and then there's the taret types
package so you can imagine someone who's
written a package about pipelining you
know you're doing a lot of the same
kinds of tasks like maybe reading files
or something it can be really useful to
have shorthand sort of targets for more
complicated things for common tasks in
data science so that's another
package now I've been using this package
for a little over a year and I'm
completely self-taught in it so um I've
made some mistakes and I just want to
share some things with you that if
you're going to start to use this
package may be uh useful to you not
everything has to be a Target it's very
tempting to kind of piece out every
little thing and add it in your pipeline
especially when you're building a big
complicated one
but there's a bit of an art I think the
key is to start with broad strokes and
then drill down into smaller pieces as
you need them larger targets when
they're skipped will give you bigger
speed UPS so that's an advantage but
smaller targets mean that you have more
control over what is skipped and what
isn't um so there's a you know you have
to kind of ask yourself a few questions
mainly does this might this target get
updated independently of other targets
if so you might want to split it out or
is this something I'll want to look at
like get my hands on um down the line
you might want to split it out as well
don't be afraid to run the pipeline so
this is kind of a I don't know if anyone
here has had this experience but when I
started coding I was always afraid of
Errors um because they're scary and
they're red and what's going on right
but I actually have learned to embrace
errors and similarly in pipelining you
will get errors when you're developing
pipelines and I would always be afraid
of running the pipeline because I didn't
want to run into errors and I don't
really understand this tool and what's
going on but it's not too hard to debug
so for instance when you run a pipel if
you run into an error targets will spit
out the last error that um it'll give
you some context it'll say hey this
target Sim errored here is the last
error and you can actually look at
previous errors as well there's some
guidance there and I'll point out that
actually the de there is a really good
debugging Guide online your Temptation
may be to uh well my sim remember my sim
object was created with uh you know I
had some data going into a function
called make forecast so you might be
tempted to Source the function wrap it
in a debug statement or maybe insert a
browser statement in there however you
like to debug load the data and then
actually run the function in your local
session don't do that it's inefficient
it works I did it for a while but it's
once you have functions that take many
many targets as arguments it becomes
unwieldy to do this so instead a really
nice trick is to insert a browser
statement into your function make a
forecast let's say you don't have to
Resource it the pipeline will take care
of that for you and then when you run
the target uh Sim you just insert this
argument that's caller function equals
null which tells targets don't use a
callar wrapper just run it in my local
session and then you'll have access to
the browser output because when you run
um if you were to run if you were TR to
try to debug the function or have a
browser in there and just run like
normal the caller subprocess won't let
you get in there like you can't get in
there to browse and look around your
function so that's a nice little trick
that has saved me a lot of
time another one is be explicit so this
is actually not this is an example of a
bad Target because if I am expecting my
case counts data set to update I have
not told targets to watch that I've
baked in that file path into a Target so
if I update the case counts data will
still look like it's up todate because
it's not clear that there's a dependency
on that file so instead you have to
First Call in the data file as format
equals file to tell it hey watch this
it's a file so you have to watch it in a
special way and then that the data
Target depends on that and then if you
update the file the the updates will
Cascade
right and finally I'll just say that I
used to be such a static brancher I used
to static Branch everything I'll explain
what that means so um static branching
what happens is the targets get get
generated before the pipeline is run so
you have to know what those targets are
going to be for instance if I want to
run a simulation for Ontario and for
Quebec I can pass you know I can tell
the pipeline to set up with those two
branches but and what's nice about that
is you get clearly named targets like
simore oen for Ontario for example so I
know what things look like but it's
actually much more annoying to set up
aggregation points if I run simulations
for two provinces I might want to
actually just do a bind rose on those
tables so that I can plot them in the
same GG
plot Dynamic branching the targets get
generated at runtime which made me very
uneasy because they have these cryptic
names so you know I don't really know
what that is and I I'm always trying to
get my grubby little hands on those
targets to see what they are when I'm
developing and the thing is though that
because it's kind of concealed for me
there is some automatic sort of stuff
that gets HP that happens with
aggregation that can be really really
helpful it becomes a lot easier actually
to branch and then reaggregate so I know
this might not be super clear because
I'm not giving you an example but if you
get into this package definitely don't
discount Dynamic
branching now my final thoughts you
don't always need a pipeline so if you
have a short one-off task you're not
necessarily going to return to it maybe
it's just for homework or I don't know
some T small task at work just maybe
write a script it's fine I still write
scripts occasionally I know it's it's
hard for me to admit that up here but um
if you have a multi-step process maybe
you'll have to run it again you'll have
to return to it you'll have to pass it
off to a colleague a pipeline can do
wonders for you because it's kind of
self-documenting
too um even though you may not always
want a pipeline you can still set
yourself up for Success so there are a
couple of coding habits that I've
adopted over the years two of which I
just want to highlight here I almost
always work so that my file structure is
compatible with targets pipelines as
well as our packages because they use
the same thing mainly that you Define
your functions in the r folder in
general I almost always work as if I'm
going to eventually write a package
because I just find it helps me really
keep myself organized you don't have to
go that extreme um but one tip is to
document your functions as if you're
going to package them and in r that
means using roxygen which has a very
standardized format I know how to read
it the function documentation is right
above the function definition it's all
in one place my colleagues know how to
read it and if I do want a package down
the line it's really easy to go and
convert that into a
package so now I really hope everyone
here is just itching to try to write a
pipeline so if you are new to pipelining
what I would suggest is read the targets
manual like I said my one of my favorite
reads of last year if not the favorite
it's really well written it's written by
someone who obviously does a lot of data
science and knows where the quirks are
of of their software and it's wonderful
um and what I would suggest is start
with a working script something maybe
you've written for a quick task and just
try to convert that and see you know how
that goes and then maybe take something
more complicated that might involve
branching and try to convert that if
you're already a pipeline user maybe
you've used other tools like make Etc um
read the targets manual it's really good
um and it's going to kind of I mean a
lot of that stuff there's some really
good motivation and prefacing for why
you should consider pipelining that
might not be new to you but um if you're
trying to get a colleague into
pipelining that's never done it before
great Gateway
and definitely check out branching crew
and taret types which are a bit more
advanced use cases have a bit more
advanced use cases so thank you I'll
mention that my slides are available
online here and there's some links and
Easter eggs in the notes if you do want
to refer back to it while you're
learning Targets later today I hope so
thank
you